there are about a million things you can
do wrong when starting up Pokemon Sun
and moons
so we've taken it upon ourselves to give
you some tips on what not to do
while adventuring in a low lap here are
some things to avoid in Pokemon Sun and
Moon don't restart the shiny pokemon
sure it's tempting to restart your game
to try and get a shiny starter pokemon
but keep in mind the getting one to
spawn is our one in 4,000 shares like
you're above it I'm still shaken and
since you have to enjoy three minutes of
dialogue every time you restart your
time is probably better spent progress
in the game so you can breed your own
shiny pokemon instead oh my god wait
don't avoid trainer battles when a
nearby trainer is looking to brawl the
screen dims making it easy to avoid the
fight if you want to but you shouldn't
skip them not only will your Pokemon get
much-needed experience but you'll also
build up a good amount of cash and snag
a few items here there plus it's a good
idea to clear the area so if you need to
backtrack you won't have these trainers
attacking you all the time don't stick
with the same team it's tempting to keep
your original six Pokemon especially
since they might be your strongest and
highest level but mixing and matching
your team isn't just part of the fun it
allows you to switch strategies to
overcome specific enemies and since you
can get the exp share item early on in
the game it's relatively easy to bring a
new lower level Pokemon up to speed with
the rest of your team after a few
battles since it'll get half the
experience your Active Pokemon earn
don't over level your Pokemon it may
sound weird but it's possible your
Pokemon could become more powerful than
you yeah it's true if you over level
your Pokemon they may stop listening to
your orders and
at level your team to the proper levels
and then complete the grand trials that
reward you with stamps on your trainer
passport that allows higher level
Pokemon to follow your commands don't
lay cash on clothing one of the coolest
features in Pokemon Sun and Moon is the
ability to customize your character's
appearance from the clothes they wear to
the hairstyles they Rock
but while it's tempting to bling
yourself out make sure you save enough
money for things that actually affect
gameplay like pokeballs provide super
potions and maybe the occasional escape
rope or two don't worry
but the end of the game you'll have
enough cash to do whatever you want
don't neglect your ride Pokemon your
ride pager is there for a reason so
don't walk around like a rube when you
can be charging your way through areas
in half the time with your tourists as
you continue the story you'll get access
to more Road Pokemon with different
abilities some of which can even net you
more items like the stout land and it's
search skills that can sniff out hidden
objects it's easy to forget that you
have these ripe Pokemon at your service
until an obstacle is in your way but be
sure to use them and to use them often
especially because they can get you to
hidden areas with cool items to collect
don't forget to save this seems like a
no-brainer but many of people forget to
save their games every so often this of
course can result in losing precious
progress either in the story or in
training of Pokemon thankfully the game
saves after you trade pokémon with
someone so you don't have to worry about
losing a new friend but there could be
worse scenarios given that the game is
on a portable console you're always in
danger of losing battery life in the
middle of an important battle or trial
so save often because you know how you
feel if you die
don't neglect Pokemon refresh want to
build up your pokemons affection and
bond with them well that's what Pokemon
refreshes for every so often you'll see
a care option on the touchscreen of your
device after a battle pressing Y will
lead you to the Pokemon refresh screen
and tasks you with either cleaning up
your Pokemon or getting rid of their
status ailments like paralysis or poison
not only that but you can feed them
cocoa beans and pet them to raise their
affection towards you
once you max out their affection they'll
be able to do cool things in battle like
dodge attacks in response to your shouts
shake-off status effects and even wish
for your praise after they land critical
hits it pays to bond with your Pokemon
don't randomly override move the
pokemons read list is what gives it
flavor in battle and can be crucial to
winning matches especially if you're a
competitive player with that set don't
just keep the leading old moves every
time your Pokemon levels up and tries to
learn a new skill the new skills might
seem cool but it's possible the old
skill is actually better luckily there
are sites to help you study up to see
which skills are best for you and your
Pokemon don't ignore the hidden zygarde
self if you notice some swirling green
or pink lights anywhere in the world you
should go up to them and investigate
these are zygarde cells and cause which
make up the Pokemon call well
zygarde it's easy to overlook them but
it's a good idea to collect as many of
these as you go so that you can create
the 10% and 50% forms eventually
collecting 100 out of 100 elements to
create the 100% form and might take some
time but if you've ever wanted a Pokemon
that kind of looks like a transformer
use your chance
thanks for watching click the Lubar icon
to subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all these cool stuff we know
you love to